hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2019 sci-fi movie called lifelike the
movie starts with a newly married couple
named sophie and james
they both are very happy with their
married life and looks like they're
moving to a new apartment bringing an
old couch
james has been working on the trust fund
run by his father who is a very rich
businessman
one day he receives a call from his
family telling him that his father has
died
automatically he inherits his father's
business and becomes ceo of his father's
company
james and sophie decide to move away
from the city into a suburban mansion
day by day they start their new life in
the mansion
they have a lot of maids to take care of
their household chores so sophie doesn't
work and spends most of her time at home
unfortunately she is not used to this
luxurious life like the maids who serve
her all the time even though her maids
have worked very well
she feels that she only wants to live
alone with james in the mansion
firmly he chooses to fire all the maids
by giving them layoffs
james who initially knows about this is
very disappointed with sophie he says
that they need some maids to take care
of their big mansion but in the end he
gets what sophie wants and they decide
to make love in the bed
at some point james who is working very
hard is called by his wife in the middle
of a meeting
sophie asks him to help start the
lawnmower in their yard
james ends up fixing the engine at night
every day sophie is still confused about
her new job she starts complaining to
james although she had fired all the
maids in her house
as a final point they meet julian a man
who sells artificially intelligent
robots to be used as domestic servants
at first james wants to rent a beautiful
robot but sophie doesn't agree because
she wants to be the only woman in their
house
finally they agree to choose a male
robot named henry who dutifully carries
out their commands around the house
in the beginning everything goes
normally henry as a robot prepares
breakfast for them every morning and
mows the grass in their yard as ordered
by james and sophie
at one time henry is cleaning sophie's
room and accidentally sees her wearing
clothes
sophie is very surprised by his presence
and asks him to get out she keeps
complaining to james about henry's
action until one day their relationship
is getting tense
sophie often feels lonely because james
is always busy at work as a result she
tries to spend more time with henry from
now on she starts to have feelings for
him she tells him to read a book about
human feelings and emotions
therefore henry begins to develop
emotions and have dreams due to the
robot's intelligence system which will
adapt to the things he faces one evening
sophie wakes up from her bed and hears
something from outside the house
she finds henry sleeping outside stark
naked and somewhat disoriented saying
that he dreams of being a human
the next day they go straight to julian
and ask about henry's strangeness last
night
julian says that it could happen because
they over developed henry's emotions
such as often doing human things with
him when they come home james blames
sophie for everything she has done to
henry
currently their relationship is getting
worse after work james finds a letter
written by sophie the letter was written
by sophie when they first moved into the
house showing how much she loved james
then he brings some candles into his
room to apologize and ask sophie to make
love
but sadly she turns it down because she
isn't really in the mood at one night
henry tells sophie that he's been
feeling some emotions lately he feels
like he was programmed to fulfill
everything that james and sophie needs
including sleeping together and making
love to them
that night sophie dreams that henry is
kissing and making love to her while
massaging her when james goes to work
sophie intentionally opens her bedroom
door and masturbates about her dream
last night afterwards she discovers
henry outside her room asking if he was
watching her recently
later james sees sophie and henry
sitting by the pool he is envious of
their recent closeness he decides to
meet up with julian again asking him a
solution for henry julian tells him that
henry's behavior will be in line with
his owner's wishes with the information
james warns henry not to interact with
his wife again
a dejected henry deliberately informs
sophie about the warning causing james
and sophie to argue once more
consequently sophie leaves the house for
the next few days
when james asks henry to bring his razor
henry comes naked the encounter between
them leads to an awkward exchange which
ends with henry kissing james this
incident makes james to question his
sexuality
the next day in his office james calls
sophie to mend their relationship
sophie secretly comes home just to meet
henry after henry kisses sophie while
massaging her sophie is disturbed when
henry mouz i love you in the same manner
used by james
when james comes home she informs him of
the encounter just now causing james
enraged he then bumps into henry and
slaps him brutally disconnecting his
charging station
the next morning james and sophie are
waiting for julian to arrive at their
home
james leaves for work first because he
has waited too long for julian that day
henry wakes up very late
suddenly he comes and wonders to sophie
about his charging station being
disconnected he also explains all the
events that happened when sophie left
the house
not long after julian comes to the house
but sophie decides to see james at his
office
oddly enough henry looks at his bruises
from the mirror questioning that he is a
robot julian orders him to go to his bed
but he doesn't want to comply
he also realizes that julian has been
lying to him all this time
back to sophie and james they both
regret their actions
james explains that he took his lust on
henry because he was previously rejected
by sophie they eventually forgive each
other's mistakes at home they are
surprised by henry naked outside henry
realizes that all along he is a human
julian is discovered to be a fraud and
all of his robots are revealed to be
real humans whom he had raised
julian had taken custody of henry when
he was a small child who was rejected by
his mother and had suffered serious
physical abuse he had raised all of them
to believe they were robots
james and sophie with two fbi agents go
to their residence to arrest julian
julian shoots them with a shotgun all of
a sudden
he points his gun at james and sophie
but then henry attacks him beating him
mercilessly with a shotgun
feeling betrayed by his maker and
ashamed for betraying his keepers henry
commits harakiri with a large knife
james and sophie cry and comfort henry
as he dies
five years later they are shown with a
young son named henry they plan to tell
their son about his namesake someday
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching